people were surprised when
vianco he exists it's the visor that
promotes he sees a lot when walking
everything
the train that calls the tail your dress
also that it's not to have anything makes you
open to offend
[Music]
my name is manuel juraci e mora  that
monte Alegre in the municipality of itatira
is a moment that this was something
that we worked with a group of 20
people from beekeeping,
then they have to bring a cart
again, go get it at my game there in a
worse place,
then the colleagues two kits  is to ask
now if you can make an outfit for a
month of work the research also gives there
I was like this and today the doll moves
beekeeper and today works in agriculture
that seeks to unite him look my son is the
following is because bee if you don't
having three fingers to get to
them is no use
and then it's a case of inventing his clothes for
him to be able to get there and also
to make the clothes of the goal is to work
was the 15 days it was only quick because
I was so lucky and  for the first
time I went to wear his clothes he
had nothing to refuse he
looks at the other beekeepers to
transport their honey and makes mistakes
tse only transport the greatest difficulty
because because he doesn't have the patience to
face this type of work that I
had here in  my way of understanding
he is a bad man that he has and I think
that this specialty of his,
right because within the work he
has been doing that is not everyone because it is
something that in another party is not just me
here and itatira who had the  intention to
make your clothes and it worked
I'm a great friend
[Music]